michel platini 21 ans dans lequel
certains voient déjà le grand patron de
l'équipe de france de demain sans club à
michel platini c'est nancy c'est ici
qu'il a grandi c'est aussi ici qu'il a
contracté le virus du football bien
avant l'âge de pouvoir chausser les
crampons car papa aldo platini
aujourd'hui entraîneur fut il n'y a pas
si longtemps un des puces les deux
footballeurs de la région michel quand
allez vous quitter papa et maman bon
principe je suis sous contrat jusqu'en
juin 79 mais sûrement à nancy jusqu'en
juin 77
après c'est ce n'est donc pas tout de
suite que nancy verra partir son
brillant numéro 10 tout le reste n'est
que rumeur destiné à entretenir le
sensationnel ces bruits latine il
accepte avec le sourire ils font partie
des retombées de la gloire la voir je
pense que c'est un grand mot mais je me
sens très bien mais pour l'affronter je
ne m'en voulez pas vous savez ça flatte
énormément puis après c'est plutôt
astreignante n'est fier d'avoir sa photo
un peu à la une des journaux mais en
contrepartie on a beaucoup de
responsabilités à côté
michel platini part promis à un bel
avenir et qui fera ses grands débuts en
équipe nationale j'ai un peu
d'appréhension mais je pense que c'est
tout à fait naturel mais non je pense
pas je crois que je vais m'en sortir